yummy um what does that mean exactly my
sex life okay
seems all's well on that front for
Justin Bieber
there's something about toes when you're
laying inside it is what it is
yeah married
[Applause]
[Music]
the pop star made an appearance on
Tuesdays Ellen Show where he candidly
addressed his marriage with wife Haley
Bieber she's an amazing amazing amazing
person she's super precious yeah I enjoy
spending my life with her he's really
funny we have a good time together he's
just really sweet he's a good kid a good
heart the Biebs says he always knew
there was a lot of love between him and
Haley he knew she'd say yes to his
proposal but he admits there was one big
worry on his mind am I able to make this
commitment as a man and be able to honor
you know what I say you know because
that's a serious commitment when you say
you're gonna love someone for better for
worse and like be faithful that's a huge
am I able to do that and so I think that
was really what I was battling with of
course JB committed a thousand percent
and the pair tied the knot in September
2018 exactly a year later they
celebrated with a lavish wedding in
South Carolina and that wedded bliss has
inspired a whole lot of new music in
fact an entire new album called changes
when is it coming out that the album is
February 14th is it really and there's
more Justin is also heading out on a
full changes arena tour I'm just really
excited for the fans to now see what
we've been working so hard on but with
touring comes complications
the singer opened up about his past
struggles growing up on the road and how
it affected him I was 15 when I really
started touring and with that being said
you're on tour you're you know the the
depletion of dopamine and the best way
for me to describe it is you know I'm
going out there every night and I'm
giving giving giving giving giving and
I'm not I don't understand how to renew
treat give myself the proper nutrients I
need back and all that sort of stuff
because I'm a kid and I'm doing all the
rest of the stuff to growing up and you
know experimenting with drugs and doing
all that sort of stuff but that was then
and this is now and JB seems to be in a
really positive place we love seeing him
smile doing what he does best
you say the word Emily yeah babe yeah
bake bake in the morning all day
[Music]